katy perry katy perry you i mean you
must be the hottest female artist in the
world right now are you
enjoying the moment are you just kind of
along for the ride or do you look at
someone like paul you kind of think i
would like that legacy i would like
people to be singing my songs in 40
years of course i think that's the
correct answer is i'm going to for the
long haul i want to have a career i hope
to have half the career that you
have or
whatever i'd be so grateful i mean
i think you've been doing this for
longer you know than i've even been
alive and you've been doing it so
incredibly well and the fact that you're
still here today
uh in 2013.
[Applause]
really
[Laughter]
the fact that you're not dead
as a performer he's about to be on this
stage just released an incredible record
i mean not everybody does it i think
there's like a handful of people that
still can do that well
yeah it's very true you brought it back
you brought it down
[Applause]
here's the thing though talking of
legacy famously paul you don't own
a big chunk of your own legacy in that
you don't have the the rights to a lot
of your songs no uh the early beatles
stuff um
it was a
carve up you know we didn't know
anything about
any of that so uh no so we got ripped
off but uh but then hey what the heck
but here's the weird thing that
i think we all remember reading the
papers about michael jackson buying the
beautiful catalogue but that was kind of
your fault
it was a it was a strange one yeah
i was working with michael at that time
why because he just wanged me up it was
over christmas and i just heard this
little boy say
hi
and i thought oh my god don't recognize
this voice who's got my private numbers
at home so i said yeah hello
hi it's michael and he started talking
do you want to make some hits
i see
yeah
so we we got together and um michael
said have you got any advice you know so
i said yeah
look this is what you're going to do
really hot it's just starting
um it just had off the wall
and i said you're going to make some
great videos
so we went off and made thriller and
things like that i said you got to get a
really good manager because it's all
going to be coming in and
it could all go out if you don't uh and
i said and you ought to think of getting
into song publishing
and so he kind of looked at me said i'm
gonna buy yours
till he did
[Applause]
[Music]
it's well it's not quite an action
figure but it's
it it is
[Applause]
come on come on guys you couldn't fool
her
excellent
[Applause]